people of the internet retro reckons who
are here I'm just a dad who loves games
and the stories they tell today we are
unboxing The Legend of Zelda tears of
the Kingdom collectors edition the first
thing that always surprises me about
these boxes is they are so much bigger
than they look in the picture like I
thought the Metroid dread collector's
edition was much bigger than it looked
here's the Metroid dread Collector's
Edition for comparison and you see there
I mean if I hold them up they're
actually pretty comparable
in terms of
the size right there you can see the
Zelda one is a little bit taller a
little bit wider but then here's where
it's really crazy look at this right
there
look at that right there now this one
quite a bit more expensive too all right
so it actually opens from the very top
here I've already cut the tape there
just slides right open like that and
then we open up and we can see there are
two major compartments one the sort of
green featuring The Zone eye pattern and
then just a solid black one here all
right so these both slide out nice and
easy together here oh my goodness and
right away I mean this is absolutely
like the gold they always do such a good
job with the gold on a lot of the Zelda
stuff look at that right there though oh
wait do I have it upside down yeah
there's the Nintendo logo all right
Nintendo logo is actually on the back
because it opens like this right here
and so you can see they do not include
the game in the steelbook
there is the artwork that a lot of us
have gotten very familiar with in the
lead up to the launch of the game
so very nice just a very premium feel
now this does feel very very similar to
the Metroid dread one very very similar
and again just so you can compare the
two there they are man look at how that
the gold one just look at how it
reflects the light
that is awesome
really nice and let's see they should be
about the same
thickness I would think you see how the
on the Zelda one it actually spells out
tears of the Kingdom whereas for
whatever reason the Metroid dread one
did not I like that because that I mean
that is collectors in mind right there
they know some people want to display
this on the Shelf all right also in this
black compartment that is on top we have
the game itself the Nintendo switch game
and major props to them for doing this
right here this was what I think a big
fail and this could just be the
collector in me but I think a big fail
of the Metroid one is that it did not
include a copy of the standard case so
when you bought Metroid dread the US
edition of the collector's edition did
not include the standard box it's really
annoying so I'm super glad to see that
they did in fact include it here now I
know there's got to be an easy way to
pop this out right I mean I don't want
to just turn it over and risk losing
this right here
all right that was a little bit
difficult to pry out right there so just
make sure you hold your game nice and
firm depending on which one you take out
first here Legend of Zelda tears of the
Kingdom yet again that pattern that has
been used throughout the marketing looks
very nice there very nice I think it's
just gonna slide across like so there we
go and so we have four sets of pins here
the back right there
Legend of Zelda tears of the Kingdom
copyrighted by Nintendo and they're not
too heavy I mean they look they actually
look more premium than they feel
because they feel pretty lightweight but
they do look very nice the gold is nice
the green is nice I feel like a lot of
companies are doing these pins these
days tell me in the comments what do you
guys use these pins for like where do
you put them how do you display them
because I got the Metroid Prime ones
that were available on the Nintendo uh
my Nintendo store but I don't have
anywhere to put it where do you actually
display these things because I want to I
want to show them off they look really
cool especially the Metroid Prime ones
the thing about these here I think if
you saw them out of context you would
have no idea that they're related to
Zelda at all unless you're just a
die-hard fan so I'm gonna go ahead and
slide those back in there all right now
let's just go ahead and lift this out so
I think this oh there we go that works
so that only was holding the game in
place right there so now there it is the
standard box for the Legend of Zelda
tears of the Kingdom can't wait to pop
this in and start playing man all right
now we make our way to the art book as
we get a nice little reflection there
hello everybody all right there we go
not as much of a reflect on this one and
you know what let me go ahead and take
off this protective plastic there we go
not quite as reflective now and you
really get to see oh wow look at how the
light hits it right there
that is a really nice effect right there
I'm loving this whole pattern right here
so this is the art book that comes
included there's a look at the back all
right don't worry no spoilers just going
to show you maybe the first page or two
the price there's a pair of glider in
the game if you didn't know that and
then right there also you get on the
side The Legend of Zelda tears of the
Kingdom art book okay now here we have
icon art poster
instructions wow I'm I'm shocked to see
that we have poster instructions here
but I've never had an icon art poster so
maybe it's important that I read them
due to the strength of the adhesive used
the adhesive tape may damage surfaces if
you attempt to remove it after
application oh okay that's very
important please consider this carefully
before placing the magnet so yeah if you
want to attach this poster sounds like
it's very similar to display I don't
know if you guys have had one of those
before but it actually it takes a magnet
that you stick that to your wall and
then the poster itself is made of metal
it just uses the magnet to attach I
actually might try and do it with those
3M command strips instead I find those
are just a lot better at being able to
take off without damaging your wall
should you ever decide to move it and I
rearrange my room a lot definitely make
sure you read those instructions before
you put it up all right and here we have
the Steel poster and I'm guessing this
is probably where the majority of the
cost comes in I mean the pins those have
to be pretty inexpensive the art book
The arbic is a hefty art book it's nice
so I could see that making up a decent
chunk of the cost as well but now we are
getting inside to the Steel poster
all right oh wow so it has like this
nice protective film
right on the top of it there
now I have to say the whole box I
thought was much bigger than I expected
this actually a little bit smaller than
what I was picturing now I'm sure you
could read and it tells you exactly how
big it is but again just for pictures
it's funny how that always works right
how perception is just a little bit
different than when you actually get it
and have it in your hands
all right so here is the part about oh
my goodness that is that is a strong
magnet right there just trying to pry it
off
and there you go icon art yeah this is
very lightweight guys this is very
lightweight so although I'm sure the
magnet would work very well as they
described it would I have no doubt that
if you're a fan of those 3M command
strips like I am the ones with the
velcro I would think this will attach
very well the only issue you might run
into is you have kind of this raised
Edge let me see if we can get it on the
camera there yeah so it's going to be
hard to get it to sit completely flush
with your wall but I still don't think
that's enough
yeah I don't think that'll be a problem
to actually hang that with the command
strips as well if you don't want to put
that magnet up that they even say has
the potential to damage your wall all
right let me know if you picked up a
copy of the collector's edition of Tears
of the kingdom and if not are you
playing the game are you enjoying it so
far as always guys thank you all so much
for watching I'll talk to you again soon